bill nye here i'm back to answer some of
your science questions this is science
support
part two
[Music]
angel supreme could be angel suprema
if the earth is round why doesn't all
the water fall off
the water is held on the earth by
gravity and get this so is the air
wait there's more not only is the earth
gravitationally pulling on the water the
water is
ever so slightly gravitationally pulling
on the earth
and see this is isaac newton's insight
he saw the apple fall off the tree and
he realized that not only
is the earth somehow pulling the apple
down but the apple is
mutually gravitationally pulling the
earth up
like dude that's so out there i know i
know miss misery how
charming my dad i don't get the internet
seriously where does it come from
like how does it work the internet is a
system of computers
and we are able to store information for
example an alphabet
or numbers can be represented by a code
that everyone's agreed on and the code
is a pattern
or a system of binary bits this is to
say either ons or offs
and you sir uh miss misery's dad i'll
bet you're of a certain age where you
remember morse code morse code is the
same thing it's either a dot or a dash
a dit or a da so we've taken it to a
whole another level of dits and daws
where we are able to store and transmit
billions
and trillions and quadrillions and
sextillions of bits
to represent language numbers
calculations
and you're part of this greater whole
what a time to be alive man
way to go chelsea briggs whoa did a
meteor just hit my home state of
michigan
everyone is calling me is the world
coming to an end
uh i would say based on my presence here
along you can't see it but there's a
crew of camera and audio people here i
don't think the world ended as we know
it
just judging insofar as you were able to
send the text i bet the world didn't end
for you
either so once in a while a meteor
streaks through the sky now for fun
i'll give you these three words meteor
means something streaking through the
sky
meteor has to do with the sky in greek a
meteorite
is what you call it when it makes it all
the way to the earth's surface as an
intact rock an asteroid is different a
comet is different i guess that's four
words
but yeah meteors come into our
atmosphere streak through the sky all
the time meteorites once in a while if
you like to worry about things
you're living at a great time because we
discovered that the ancient dinosaurs
were almost certainly wiped out
by a great big asteroid or a cluster of
asteroids
why can't i walk through solid objects
if all i'm made of is neurons protons
and electrons so let me say
i think you tossed in the word neuron
when you may have meant
neutron but neurons enable you to think
about this
and keep in mind that protons and
electrons are not all you're made of
there's also
some energy driving these things around
making them interact and there are this
fabulous subatomic particles the
subatomic particles are in turn made of
others
even smaller particles quarks and so
these things all interact
and if you like to wonder about things
this is a great thing
we are made of protons neutrons and
electrons and the reason you can't
walk through solid objects the reason
objects like you
are solid is because these things
especially the electrons repel each
other
so when you try to push on something the
electrons repel each other
so strongly that we perceive it as a
solid object
all the electrons neutrons and protons
came together and they are almost
entirely made
of exploded ancient stars
so you and i are made of stardust you
and i
are at least one way that the universe
knows
itself whoa dude i hope that fills you
with reverence i hope you stop and think
about that at least once every day
middle school span teacher to true are
the seats in the front of the plane the
best to avoid turbulence
generally yeah uh especially swept wing
aircraft will do this and it reminded
some aeronautical engineers of a dutch
person on ice skates
so traditionally it's called dutch roll
and you damp out the dutch roll with the
rudder
on the vertical tail so yeah generally
the front of an airplane is smoother
than the back but this is a pretty
subtle effect in the modern world
maybe on an old md-80 or dc-9
mcdonald douglas-9 aircraft or maybe
even on
md-80 and maybe even an old 707 you'd
feel that but nowadays hardly ever
why because of the coupling of stability
and control and our understanding of
computers
and our ability to have computers to not
only do uh position velocity
acceleration
and jerk but also snap whoa
carry on sit wherever you like that
alicia underscore blackberry
writes does anyone really know how
gravity works
the answer is we know with extraordinary
precision what gravity will do
we can land spacecraft on mars taking
into account general and special
relativity the speed of the spacecraft
and the influence of the earth's gravity
on
the rate at which we perceive time
passing we can take that into account to
have your cell phone tell you which side
of the street you're standing on we can
do that but where
gravity actually comes from remains a
mystery alicia blackbeard
you are living at a time when we may
discover how this happens
last summer we built these big
interferometry
gravitational observatories and we
observed
the ripple of a very strong
gravity wave all the other energy that
we can come across like the energy the
light that's bouncing off my head and
going into this camera lens and then off
your computer screen into you
we understand that very well and we use
waves to analyze
this flow of energy well people who
discovered relativity einstein's the
famous guy
realized that gravity should perhaps
also travel in waves and we could make
predictions with that and we built these
observatories and we've discovered them
proved that they existed who knows what
the future holds it's an exciting time
go wild shea at singer underscore
shay 17. if trees produce oxygen then
can't paper do the same thing if it's
made out of trees
i i understand the premise of your
question but compare
how well a fish swims when it's alive
with how well it swims after you've
caught it and killed it
we make paper out of dead trees dead
trees don't
move around as much and they don't
produce nearly as much oxygen
carry on shave jules watch them i was
just thinking
that's good i'm glad jules as artificial
intelligence becomes more intelligent we
might want to stop
using the term artificial to describe it
i mean the best
ai is one that learns itself right so
is it really artificial either way let's
not start off on the wrong foot
heart symbol icon emoji thing uh
artificial intelligence
gets the term because humans created
computers that act as though
they are what you and i call intelligent
for me
the line that will be crossed is when
our computer systems which are
artificially intelligent
choose to make art when an artificial
intelligence
decides to do something just for the
sake of doing it then we will have
crossed a line into intelligence so
right now i'd stick with ai
and don't be freaked out about a.i you
get on a
you go to an airport you get on the tram
that takes you from terminal a to
terminal c
and you trust it because engineers have
designed a system that figures out how
much you weigh how much your luggage
weighs how fast the door should open
where it should stop how fast it should
accelerate how fast it should slow down
gets all that done and you trust it it's
just the next few levels with the thing
will get more and more complicated what
we don't want
is for worldwide systems of the
artificial intelligence
to become so sophisticated that we can't
predict what they're going to do
or there's so many moving parts you
can't tell what's going to happen
that's what we don't want that's how we
get blackouts and electrical grids and
stuff but you're out there jules you're
thinking deep thoughts way to go
at a yo tristan did i just hear thunder
in a snowstorm is that a thing yeah it's
a thing thunderstorms happen
when it's cold enough for snow to form
and you know what you observe that
yourself
way to go yokimo at yoshiflo13157012
writes i have no pinky toenail is this
evolution
you'll notice that in evolution what's
an interesting thing a fascinating thing
a very important idea in evolution
yokimo
you don't have to be any better than you
have to be this is to say there is no
force no natural force no natural
selecting
pressure to have superpowers to have
x-ray vision to be able to
run faster than a speeding locomotive or
leap tall buildings in a single bound
there's no motivation for that
naturally you only have to be good
enough so if you're able to live your
life put on shoes run
marathons whatever you might do dance
swing dances maybe the balboa or the
collegiate shag or east coast swing you
can do all that without a toenail
there's no evolutionary pressure for you
to get
one but it's a cool question and you
know what else yokimo
i bet you really have one it's just the
nail bed is really small
i'm back carry on at vladimir older
question
if hashtag climate change that caused
the end of the last ice age was a good
thing
why is hashtag climate change today a
bad thing can anyone explain
first you know as we say in comedy by
the premise by the bit
what makes you think climate change the
cause of the ice age was a good thing
ogg and aguette over there and what is
now france they had it going on they
lived in caves
they hunted gathered and scavenged they
had sex they carried on who knows what
they buried their dead carefully why was
that a good thing everything got hot
people started walking all over the
earth i mean was that really good but
why the reason
climate change today is a bad thing is
the speed
it's the rate at which humans like you
and i are causing
climate change that's the problem you
and i are causing climate change
and it's the speed people are going to
have to abandon coastal cities
as their floods come in more and more
frequently the pests that
infect our crops pests are showing up
earlier and sticking around later
it's the speed vladimir alder that is
the trouble and whether or not
ice age ending was a good thing it
depends on whom you
ask go out there if you go back in time
take a meeting with ogg and i'll get and
see if they thought it was great when
they're mosquitos all the time
suck man brunette love seven writes at
bill nye
my boyfriend and i have been debating if
water is wet
i went into the convo conversation
thinking it is but he is adamant
water is not wet can you please explain
the science behind the answer to this
question
for me wet is sort of defined by water
yeah
so if there's water present it's
generally going to be wet
with that said we in fluid mechanics
think of
air wetting the surface of a baseball or
a bird's wing or an airplane
we talk about wetting and here's the
definition of wetting from a fluid
mechanical standpoint for your
consideration myra brunetta
it's when the fluid sticks to the
surface air is a fluid anything that
flows is a fluid
so if it sticks to the surface then the
surface is wetted
so try this get a flask spin it
with water in it spin it and you'll see
the water takes on
some of the spin of the glass because
it's stuck to the surface
take a ping-pong ball and give it a lot
of spin either with a racket a paddle or
your fingers
the air sticking to the surface wetting
the surface
influences its flake but now whacks the
hood of a car
and put water droplets on it they beat
up they don't wet the surface
whoa
thank you for these questions i'm really
glad you all are pondering these things
i am not some brilliant guy okay i'm
just scientifically literate but the
questions so far
have been addressed in science and
they're very well understood and you and
i depend on them that's why we have
shapes made of glass and lenses and
drinkable water and
electronic computer machines is because
of science
carry on people